ama bakarak
bir sıkıntı fon müzik aç
ya hayy oylo ya böyle you do
Ya anne doğal olur mu
Herkese merhaba
selam söyle Sizleri çok mu
abone ol
ne anlar anlamı karadan La La La La La
La La La La La La La La La Mahalleye
Geldin Geleli Canım kaldık fikir ki
bu oyunda ayda bir öyle yavrum Çaldık
arkadaşlar birbirimizi sula o
bu birisi olur mu de erkeğin delikanlı
mısın kız mısın anlayalım artık o Usta
son başımıza bela mısın acaba mahalleye
geleceğim canım ya
127 bitir tutturduk çıkıyor çıktı mı
o çıtır çıtır
abone ol
bu Ellerinize sağlık Ağzınıza sağlık
Buradan öyle gördüm ki çok güzel eşlik
ettiğiniz çok teşekkür ediyoruz sizlere
bunlar için biz bugün sesler sus
akapellah olarak Ankaralı bir grubun
sizlerin karşısındayız çok heyecanlıyız
Bunun için size dört tane Eser
hazırladık iki tanesini söyledik Şimdi
üçüncü söyleyeceğiz hepsi birbirinden
farklı tarzlarda birer tane örnek olması
için şimdi bir tane de Türk'ü
düzenlemesi yapacağız hepinizin
bildiğinizden Emin olduğumuz bir eser
lütfen Hep Birlikte söyleyelim Haydi
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
bakalım
Bu numaranın baram baram baram ha ha
[Müzik]
Az önce be Acem Sence berapa bana aşık
olur oğlum canı sana aşık oldum sana
Yanıyorum Yanıyorum Hele
[Müzik]
ve Acem Şalı ince bele Acem Şalı yiyince
blr Yanıyorum Yanıyorum Yanıyorum Hele
Eba Hayır oldum da gel açayım salı
yiyince be Acem Şalı ince bele
Rahatladın mı
abone ol
Çok sağolun Ellerinize sağlık Ağzınıza
sağlık ayaklarınıza sağlık buraya kadar
geldiğiniz için yani derbinin olduğu gün
burada olmanız değil mi derbimi Doğru mu
o kadar biliyorum derbinin olduğu gün
burada olmanız Ayrıca mutluluk verici
onu size söyleyeyim
bu Harikasınız bu saate kadar beklemiş
olmamız da muhteşem bir şey Tekrar hoş
geldiniz tekrar sefalar getirdiniz
efendim altyapı şöyle birşey önce bir
davul lazım davul müziğin kalp atışları
dır yani müziğin yaşadığını gösterir Biz
de bu nasıl bir şeydir örnek bulamama
bulmam bulamadım bulamadım an ama söz
olsun
abone ol
çok Azına sağlık soğan kağıdı dolubaş
dünya çapında bir davulcu dur kendisi
Tabi bunu ağzıyla yapıyor peki bu
o kalp atışı dır dedik ritim şarkının
kalp atışı dır ve yaşadığını gösterir
aynı zamanda bir insan oraya birşey daha
eklemek zorundadır ki o odada ruhtur
Buna da bas diyoruz
bu işte o da Tolga Sarıkaya İşte bu
ikisini alta temele böyle güzelce
yerleştirdiğiniz zaman bir müziğin kalp
atışları olduğunda Üstüne bir de ruhu
olduğunda onun üstüne ne koyarsanız
koyun gider
Ama bunlar neler Mehmetciğim terör ümüz
Sağ ol canım benim ağzına sağlık İnci
erkek sesi çok güzel söylüyor Ben asla
Şahin Arto kalın sesli kadın sesinde
söylüyorum Elif Koda ayto kalın sesli
kadın sesinde söylüyor ve ince sesli
kadınlarımız var onlarda ipekel Ağzına
sağlık Ellerine sağlık ve İlayda da çok
teşekkürler bir müziğin kalp atışlarını
ve ruhunu sağlam bir zemine
yerleştirdiğinizde üzerine koyacak bir
Ruha daha ihtiyaç var O da şimdi
söyleyeceğiniz parçada Lütfen burada
kalan herkesle birlikte hep birlikte
söylemek istiyoruz ses ver sus akapellah
Ankaralı bir grup sizlerle birlikte
Evet şimdi bir parça daha söyleyeceğiz
beraber söyleyelim Hazır mıyız Haydi
bakalım tampon ya
bu dünya yazılacak mı Şaka şaka yaptım
da duramam duramam duramam araba
programdır program o
o tutturduk endurdum da o
bugün sizlere be akapellah nasıl yapılır
4 adet örnek gösterdik bir tanesi
yabancı Payı parçaydı bir tanesi Türkçe
popüler bir eserdi bir tanesi Türkçe bir
türküydü ve son olarak her koronun
söylediği gibi bir martı buna bunların
hepsini çok güzel eşlik ettiğiniz çok
teşekkür ediyoruz Sağolun var dalın
tekrar başka bir etkinlikle görüşmek
üzere